before coming to the Jackson Institute
it's true I did serve at the Department
of home
ready for more than two years and I
worked closely with the secretary and
got to know her well I'm often asked
what does she really like in private so
for the purpose of today I thought I
would mention two traits that are not
always on display in public one she is a
tremendous sports fan enthusiastically
adopting the local sports teams where
she finds herself living and second she
is very very very competitive in all
facets of her life in her work and
including her support of the local
sports teams so in the spirit of a warm
welcome to the Jackson Institute in Yale
I would just like to point out Madam
Secretary that the Yale Bulldogs
trounced Georgetown a couple weeks ago
in football yeah so I'm just saying yeah
I think I may have just been added to
the no-fly list the the Department of
Homeland Security was created is a
response to the September 11 terrorist
attacks more than 20 federal agencies
were hastily brought together under one
roof and when it opened its doors on
march first 2003 the department was at
once the third biggest department in the
federal government with more than
250,000 employees it had to quickly
consolidate into one unified department
near those nearly two dozen agencies
each with their own legacies their own
set of cultures in their own way of
doing things and it was given five
missions crucial to the safety and
security of the United States prevent
another terrorist attack on our soil
prevent a devastating cyberattack on our
critical networks protect our nation's
borders enforce the country's
immigration laws and prepare for and
respond to both human caused and natural
disasters
and by the time Barack Obama was like
the president and asked our speaker to
be his Secretary of Homeland Security
many were openly questioning the
department's value was it too large and
too cumbersome for its own good FEMA had
become in the wake of Katrina the very
symbol of bureaucratic failure the
color-coded alert system that played in
airports was helpful pretty much only to
late-night comedians and the employee
morale at the department was was at the
bottom of all federal agencies but those
who worried that the department couldn't
be fixed or who thought the spirit of
its employees couldn't be rallied or who
wondered if the department was just too
big for one person to lead never met
Janet Napolitano before she was the
two-term Governor of Arizona call by
Time magazine is one of the five best
governors in the country she had been
the Attorney General for Arizona and the
US attorney before that first woman to
be chair of the National Governors
Association today she has led a complete
and total transformation of the
department she has been tireless in her
pursuit of better more innovative more
effective strategies to protect the
homeland there are more resources
guarding our borders than ever before
immigration enforcement is smarter and
at record highs on her watch FEMA is now
a symbol of responsiveness and its work
has been praised by governors of both
political parties from all across the
country and those color-coded threat
warnings have been replaced with a
system that communicates real threat
information in real time in places it's
trust in the American people it is my
great honor to welcome to the stage for
discussion about the international
aspects of Homeland Security someone who
has been praised as the most competent
public servant in government today and
the rock star of the cabinet ladies and
gentlemen the Secretary of Homeland
Security Janet Napolitano
thank you I don't know about that
Rockstar thing oh good afternoon it's
pleasure to be up here at Yale and to
see all of you and to be here at the
Jackson Institute I appreciate the
invitation I am going to keep my remarks
brief and I'm going to speak about the
International aspects of Homeland
Security in part because that component
of our work is often counterintuitive
but as Jim said I really want to leave
most of our time for questions and
dialogue with the students here so i
will speak briefly i'm often asked when
i say i'm going to speak briefly they
look at me and they say you know Janet
you're a lawyer and you're a politician
what exactly does that term mean to you
and and I will relate a story told to me
by mike huckabee the then governor of
Arkansas who tells the tale of the
writing professor who said he would give
the highest grade to a student who wrote
the shortest story containing four
fundamental elements and the four
fundamental elements were religion
royalty sex and mystery religion royalty
sex and mystery and the highest grade
went to the following Oh God said the
Queen I'm pregnant and I don't know who
did it so
and in in the spirit of that you can all
use that story I don't care I want to
speak with you about the fact that
Homeland Security is really national
security and that Homeland Security is
really international in nature and to do
that I want you to travel with me back
in time to christmas day of 2009 I was
actually at my brother's house out in
the Bay Area president was in Hawaii and
we got a secure call by the way when
you're when you're out doing your
christmas day walk and your Secret
Service agent comes to find you and says
you need to make a secure call to the
White House you know that's not going to
be a good call and something is
something has happened and something
that it happened was an attempted
terrorist attack on a detroit-bound
flight flight 253 out of Schiphol
Airport in Amsterdam to to the United
States and although that flight it was a
US flag carrier flying into a US city it
actually involved passengers if this had
succeeded passengers from some 17
different countries who would have
perished the alleged attacker was a man
named Umar Farouk Abdulmutallab he was a
Nigerian citizen educated in the United
Kingdom he received training on
terrorist tactics in Yemen he purchased
his ticket in Ghana he flew from Nigeria
to Amsterdam before departing for
Detroit he was in Canadian airspace when
he attempted to blow up the aircraft
using explosive known as PETN that he
had packed in his underwear hence the
name he has been given the underwear
bomber he's on trial today by the way
his trial just started in Detroit he was
under
successful not because he didn't evade
the layers of security that we have but
because the passengers on the plane
noticed something amiss with him and
went over and put out the detonation
device before it could actually detonate
the explosive if he had been successful
he had enough PETN on his body to
probably take down the entire aircraft
that my friends is a homeland security
problem it's a homeland security problem
why because it Illustrated that
information that we had in databases
possessed by customs part of Homeland
Security needed to be shared overseas at
last points of departure where we have
air carriers and air screeners part of
the TSA also part of Homeland Security
that we couldn't just view the world's
oceans as a a free zone it was
international in nature because it
revealed that once you get into the
world's aviation system you potentially
have access to all of it and if you have
access to all of it you have access to
all of it for purposes of blowing it up
you have access to all of it for
purposes of terrorists travel you have
access to all of it for other nefarious
reasons as well and once we once we got
through the immediate crisis of the
moment and we realized that AB the
McCollum was there weren't others out
there on other flights and we got our
are the setting back we got I've got
them got this thing back under control
in that sense we took a step back and
said you know this really is a global
aviation issue it's not a homeland
security issue and so we began reaching
out to institutions like the United
Nations which has a civil aviation
organization under it called the ICAO
and
and rather than putting together a u.s.
initiative around the world we went into
partnership with icao and set up
regional summits around the world and we
had to move quickly because we realized
that the level of security at airports
around the world it needed to quickly be
improved and at every number of levels
we had over the course of i think five
or six months regional summits in spain
tokyo we had regional summits in abuja
nigeria in the UAE and in mexico city
for the Western Hemisphere and it all
culminated in an international meeting
in Canada nine months after the fact
which is record time for the UN by the
way that's normally by the time they
finished their first draft of a document
but we were bringing it to the entire
national body international body and
getting agreement uniformly among the
nations of the world on what needed to
be done within nine months that was all
international work done under the rubric
of Homeland Security I'll give you a
second example of the international
nature of our work and it also involves
air travel not surprisingly but one of
the key tools that we have in terms of
protecting the United States both from
acts of terrorism or other international
crime is to know travel patterns and how
people are traveling and where and what
routes they have taken and to be able to
search for travelers based on their
travel patterns based on those travel
routes and to do so in a way that allows
us to get as much information about
travelers 72 hours in advance to
increase the likelihood that we are
going to find somebody we and we process
almost 2 million passengers a day in the
United States we have the largest most
complex aviation system in the world
that involves reaching agreement
across the globe including right now
negotiating one with the European Union
and what's interesting there is that
gets you into for those of you that have
studied the EU or are they are a
different regime now they have something
called the Lisbon Treaty the Lisbon
Treaty gives the European Parliament
basically approval authority on
international agreements even those
involving security and so we are in the
process of working with the European
Commission the council of ministers and
we will be going to the Parliament
trying to draft a agreement on how we
get advanced passenger information from
the EU and exchange it back and how we
do it not for particular eyes persons
for which we already have data and
reasonable suspicion but how we do it
systemically so that people who meet
certain parameters can be pinned against
the system for at least a secondary
examination so that's number two a third
way that we are intersecting
internationally is in the entire area of
the protection of our nation's
intellectual property and the protection
of our nation's cybersecurity the cyber
security area as you all know respects
no national boundaries it has no laws no
international protocols or conventions
govern it it is really a free-for-all in
cyberspace and that means attacks
intrusions can come from anywhere in the
world and cause massive damage massive
damage not only to the government but
also to the private sector and
particularly the private sector that
controls our nation's infrastructure and
so we are just I believe at the
beginning of understanding what needs to
be done to really protect cyberspace in
the non-military environment but that is
something that responsibility that we
have at the department and that I think
we will be retaining
even as the Congress begins to draft a
law governing authorities and that means
that we consistently have to be looking
around the world and thinking
internationally with respect not only to
how we protect the country in in
cyberspace but also how we protect the
nation's economic health from threats
and are from thefts excuse me that our
cyber space dependent and that of course
is international in nature and involves
us and some very tricky questions so
what are some of the issues that arise
in this environment well where does
Homeland Security and and national
security begin I believe they are
intrinsically and inextricably blended
that's a question what is the role of
the department of homeland security visa
V the State Department visa V the
Department of Defense visa V some of the
other larger departments of the federal
family that sometimes gets worked out on
a situational basis it's not easy to
draw bright lines and organizational
charts that anticipate every
eventualities how does the Department of
Homeland Security ensure that Homeland
Security equities are taken into account
when decisions are being made in the
interagency that may not be Homeland
Security specific how do we make sure
that those things are thought about and
then lastly what new tactics techniques
other things can we employ and deploy to
enlarge our abilities and as we do all
of this always being confronted with
very difficult questions about not just
where does Homeland Security and the
national security begin but where does
Homeland Security and and privacy begin
where do programs policies initiatives
that we are undertaking possibly be
viewed as infringing on other
constitutional rights and
how do we make sure that we are making
decisions and making that and making
that balance in a calculated way in an
intentional way not being accidental or
careless with some of the vast powers
that we may have so these are all
extremely easy areas there are very
clear answers there's always a right and
Iran and by the way and if you believe
that you probably shouldn't be the
Secretary of Homeland Security but in
any event that very briefly gives you a
synopsis of some of the work that we are
doing in the international sphere but as
professor Smith said we also in addition
to terrorism prevention have some of the
other major areas that you've heard
about border security immigration
enforcement and of course disaster
preparation and response under our wings
as well so it's more than enough to keep
us busy and it's something I'm very
passionate and speaking about so thank
you for having me here today
students two microphones you can please
line up
our way hello my name is Lincoln
Mitchell and I'm from Oklahoma and my
question to you is just how would how do
you feel about the Arizona illegal
immigration law and what would be your
ideal solution to illegal immigration
both for illegal immigrants who are
coming over and those who are already
here well I think I think the courts
have spoken on the arizona immigration
law at least at least the Ninth Circuit
has and we supported the Department of
Justice in that lawsuit to say that it
infringed on federal government's
ability to have primacy in the
immigration arena so it's it was a law
too far but it is understandable that
states are acting why because Congress
has enacted and the current immigration
law doesn't match our nation's needs and
it doesn't it doesn't take into account
the different circumstances that
immigrants have it's it's too hard to
become a legal immigrant and we have too
many restrictions we don't have enough
visas force for students for certain
types of workers and the like we have
wait waiting lists that are years and
years long in other countries do you
know our country is a great magnet we
always have been so the ultimate
solution is for Congress to begin really
taking up the question of immigration do
I think they're going to do that anytime
soon probably not much as we wish they
would we're ready at the drop of a hat
to tell more collaboratively with them
on that but until they do it's our job
to enforce the law that we have and do
it in a smart way really trying to focus
priorities in a reasonable way and
that's what we're that's what we are
doing thank you Thanks hi I'm Betsy
Cooper I'm a law student from Buffalo
New York and my question is also about
immigration one of the different things
about the immigration area and homeland
security compared to other things like
tear
ism prevention might be that there's
also a benefit side in your department
you do you know integration and
citizenship and sort of more of the
positive things which is great but also
sort of strangely under the heading of
Homeland Security so some advocates have
proposed separating those positions out
into a different department or agency
and I was just wondering your thoughts
on that idea yeah it is it is kind of
interesting that we have that it's
called citizenship and immigration
services which is the legalization part
of immigration you know I could argue it
both ways but here's the deal it's in
the department I don't think Congress
has the appetite to change that there is
a certain logic to having the
enforcement on the illegal side together
with the opportunities under the legal
side we really see it all and I think
you know my job is to see how we can
make those things work as smoothly as
possible and smooth away as much as we
can for legal immigration one of the
things we have done by the way is set up
a consolidated website for students who
are international students who are here
under a student visa and they want to
stay or what have you and to get that
information out and be interactive with
them it's an interactive website so that
they can begin working on that process
hopefully not the day before graduation
which is too late by the way so but
there is a process that we can work with
them on thank you yeah hi i'm josh
silverstein I'm a law student from New
Jersey I wanted to ask you about cyber
security and I think it's clear that
this is both a state and a non-state
threat and I wanted to know whether
there are different ways that the
department's gearing up to confront
those similar but quite different
threats yeah and by state and you mean
whether they're like a national
government in origin as opposed to an
individual actor in another country and
you are right and you have to think
about it both ways and somewhat
differently is an intrusion and a
theft of defense-related secrets is that
someone who just wants the technology or
is it a foreign country that wants to
deploy it is the intrusion into the
control system of a of a large
telecommunications entity a an instance
of an international competitor or
whether it's somebody trying to attack
your infrastructure and weed and I think
we do need to think about those things
differently why because the the state
action really leads to more metaphors
acts of war you know this is an act of
war how do you do cyber warfare and you
may have heard some of this the speakers
on the Pentagon starting to speak in
terms of their cyber command you know
very military in depiction and that's
really state action the state action can
also implicate Homeland Security so I
think you can tell by this answer that
we really are struggling with that and
what how does this work and how does the
federal government organized itself
because the threats can be so different
in nature but but trust me these things
are coming at us by the thousands now
and so a daily and there have been some
very deep intrusions in the United
States and so how we handle that at the
on the diplomatic side on the DoD side
security side it's really it's it's
really an area where there's no clear
doctrine right now Thanks yeah I am a
Dermot Lynch I'm a law student as well
from Denver Colorado so I wanted to ask
you about Secure Communities you say
that secure communities is about tarting
the worst of the worst it seems like
only about twenty percent of the people
who get picked up in secure communities
really are the worst of the worst or
level 1 offenders in your parlance and
there are a lot of you know local police
departments including the New Haven
Police that really don't like the idea
of being seen in any way as
enforcing immigration law having to be
co-opted and conscripted into running
these ID checks and having to get
entangled with Immigration and Customs
Enforcement that's certainly not their
priority so I'm wondering and also the
recent task force that you commissioned
seemed evenly divided on whether we
should continue even with secure
communities in fact some members of the
committee resigned rather than endorsing
d.h the committee's ultimate findings so
I'm wondering first of all have you in
any way taken the advice of those
members who really do think this
undermining this is undermining public
safety and secondly I was wondering if
you could point me to the statutory
authority for secure communities and if
you can explain it to me yeah let me
first explain for the audience you may
not know what it is what it is it is an
interoperability agreement between the
Department and the FBI and basically it
says that when the FBI runs someone's
fingerprints against criminal databases
they also run them against immigration
databases and if someone is in the
country illegally and these are people
who have been booked into jails and
prisons if they're in that country
illegally before they are released back
into the public ice has the opportunity
to come over to flag them and make a
decision whether to pick them up or not
whether to hold them in detention or not
Isis immigration and customs enforcement
and the whole goal is and and and and
I'll tell you I think secure communities
is really the answer to a big problem
that existed and I speak as someone who
was raised in New Mexico and live my
adult life in Arizona I'm a border
person but that is that the criminal
justice system would handle somebody and
then release them back in the community
and nobody would know and they were here
illegally and there was no there was no
connection between the two legal systems
both found it on by the way the rule of
law and what Secure Communities does is
through an interoperability agreement
fix that issue it doesn't
require an opt-in nor does it ultimately
have an opt-out it will be in every jail
that's using FBI databases ultimately by
2013 will have this linkage made and it
has permitted us to make some really
radical change and that is when I when I
came in into this position if you looked
at the composition of who was being
detained and removed from our country we
detained remove about 400,000 people a
year that's that's how much we have
money for that's how much the courts
have the room for it was very odd Hoke I
know and what we are seeing now is that
over half of the individuals who are
detained and removed this year over half
will have actual criminal convictions
and two thirds of the remainder will fit
other priorities that we have IE we
found them right at the border so we
don't want to return you know we want to
turn them back they are fugitives from
an existing warrant they have multiple
offenses on the immigration side so we
using secure communities as one of our
tools have been able to finally put some
priorities into immigration enforcement
that didn't exist before nobody has
questioned a statue authoritative can I
give you the the USC site office on my
head no but there has been no lawsuit or
litigation brought there and since we've
been sued on everything else I think it
would have been raised but I ask people
to step back and really look at what
secure communities is and what it
permits us to do and it really permits
us in an area of extraordinary
difficulty where you have 10 million
people in the country illegally probably
where you can only remove four hundred
thousand a year to act like prosecutors
and set priorities and then because if
one of your priorities is to find people
who are violating laws in addition to
the immigration laws the logical place
start looking for them is in jails and
prisons and that's what Secure
Communities allows us to do thank you
thank you a lot hi my name is Jason
tubes I'm a sophomore economics student
my questions about cybersecurity you
mentioned the need to protect
infrastructure and I know the DoD has
been saying similar things however given
the fact that a lot of the nation's
infrastructure is owned and run by
private companies how will the
department work with these private
companies to provide security before the
attack without infringing on say free
trade you know principles right this is
actually something that's being hashed
out and will be hashed out in the
Congress because the Senate has a cyber
bill and the house is going to have a
cyber bill and one of the issues is
should private companies particularly
those who operate critical
infrastructure be mandated by law to do
certain things should they be
incentivized somehow to do certain
things ie if they do certain things they
would have a safe harbor from litigation
for example or should you just leave it
to the market and decide that them they
will go to where the market gives them
the best answer the Senate bill is more
of what I would call a heavy incentive
bill it's not a mandate bill the House
bill as it came out of committee the
other day is more a free market bill and
so that very interesting question about
how those two systems interact or how
those two different approaches to the
problem should be addressed that's going
to be you know hashed out in the
Congress from our standpoint i take the
incentive point of view I think you
start there before you go to a mandate
and then see what happens but I don't
think you given the importance and given
the kinds of intrusions we're seeing and
also some of the behaviors we have
already seen I would not be confident
that the market itself is a sufficient
protector thank you yeah my name is
Shawn ton and I'm masters student
international relations from Malaysia
and my question is we all know that
since 911 has not been successful
terrorist attack on the United States
and I was wondering and you talked about
the seemingly random nature in which the
underwear bomber would spoil my question
is is this because it is the fact that
there hasn't been successful at tax in
to 911 is that because we've just been
really lucky or is it because of the
great system the Department of Homeland
Security had set down and if it's the
former and/or the former to a very large
extent than how much longer do you think
I'll that can hold up well I think a
couple of things one is every time there
is somebody who gets through the layers
it gives us the ability to fix things
retro actively like as I said we've
already joined now the systems that were
held on this side of the ocean of the
systems held abroad that is a huge layer
of protection that didn't exist before
but just use the 911 attack as a before
and after if you look at the world prior
to September 11 the the intelligence
gathering that was focused on Homeland
oriented al-qaeda activities not nearly
as strong as today visas visa security
and not nearly as strong as they are
today these these guys all traveled with
visas a lot more controls or information
about people who are traveling certain
routes that may have picked up some of
these guys today that wasn't had before
what you can get on an airport on an
airplane obviously different flight
schools background checks before foreign
students at flight schools weren't done
before done now even to the point of the
for 911 the cockpit didn't
door it was just a curtain and now of
course there's a hardened door so that
nobody can weaponize and air an airplane
anymore so before and after and and so
every time there's there has been an
attempt there's also been a response and
a fix and there's we're always thinking
ahead in terms of what more needs to be
done and and how to do it most
efficiently and effectively so there
have been other attempts other things
that have been thwarted some that have
not made it into the press but others
have the times square bomber a guy named
Ozzie out of Denver the student was from
Denver just a minute ago Denver all
right omakase okay yeah and allah ki was
from New Mexico I don't know what's
going on out there but in any event so
you know all those things go together
but that's not to say and in response to
your question is there a likelihood or
is there a possibility that something
will still get through or probably more
likely something will will emanate from
within the United States itself a
so-called homegrown terrorist or plot
and as much as we are doing we can't
guarantee that something will not either
get through the various layers we have
or succeed at the homegrown level yeah
yes sir Madam Secretary my name is
Armando goglia I'm a sophomore in
college and I was born in Caracas
Venezuela and in your on topic of better
enforcement of our immigration laws and
your August eighteenth letter to Senator
Dick Durbin you mention I'm sorry
Senator Durbin mm-hmm you mentioned that
there are 300,000 cases currently in
immigration courts and that these cases
are going to be reviewed by a joint
committee between the Department
justice and homeland security on a case
by case basis for review I was wondering
if this committee is already being
formed and if if it is going to be
formed when the cases will begin to be
reviewed ya know the joint committee has
been well underway they're obviously hit
the problem we're trying to to solve is
when you start saying look in the
immigration system you should have
priorities what do you do with the fact
that the immigration courts were clogged
with cases that were low priorities that
were taking the time and the resources
that we wanted to spend on higher
priority cases so what do you what you
know you can set priorities for new
cases coming in but what do you do what
the case is already in the system and
some of those cases obviously have been
pending for several years I mean the
courts take forever and the immigration
arena why because they're clogged and
what are they clogged with they're
clogged with a lot of really low
priority matters that are going to get
dismissed at the end anyway how do we
know that because we deal with hundreds
of thousands of these cases and we know
what the outcomes are going to be so
rather than let them fill up the time
and not be able to really focus on the
high-priority docket we're now in the
process of reviewing the existing cases
from the mass what's called the master
docket and that's 300,000 320,000 some
odd it matters so there is a joint
committee between DHS and the Department
of Justice they are beginning the
process they're piloting in a couple of
a couple of districts right now to see
what works and what doesn't because and
you want to do it that way because
scalability is an issue and you want to
see what works and doesn't work but we
are well underway on that that process
thank you yeah hi I'm Matthew Kim I'm a
first year graduate student at the
Jackson Institute for Global Affairs and
I actually graduated from emory
university
last year where you gave the
commencement address Oh raw um you get a
2 / in one year honey that's what what
do you got to do okay unfortunately I
couldn't attend the commencement address
I was in I have the DVD show uh um but
the wonders of YouTube has allowed me to
see your very inspirational commencement
address I'd like to ask a more of a
personal question today I was watching
also the Tuscan memorial service where
you briefly quoted from the Bible the
book of Isaiah chapter 40 you said those
who hope in the Lord will renew their
strength they will soar wings like
eagles they will walk and not be faint
they will run and not be weary I'd like
to ask you if you prescribe to a certain
religion if so how has your religious
faith affected your life in your work
now what he's referring to is the
memorial service in Tucson after the
shootings there last January where
representative Giffords was critically
injured the chief judge of the district
was murdered one of her staffers was
murdered several others it was really a
horrible situation and the president and
I went out there and and participated in
a memorial service together and I did
you have a good memory i did quote the
book of isaiah in my remarks and i am a
Protestant i am a christian and i try to
uphold and live my life by those beliefs
thank you madam secretary my name is
Aaron Gertler I'm a freshman in yale
college and my question relates to cyber
security given that it seems like China
right now is sort of almost you would
say building an army of people who are
very skilled in cyber security as well
as offensive cyber attacks do you
believe the United States is currently
training skilled computer users
at a rate that will allow us to counter
the effects of this training by China
over the next few years and if not do
you believe that the United States
education system could do more to
develop a number of skilled experts on
cybersecurity that will enable us to
counter this sort of build up yeah no
and yes no I don't think we're training
enough I think that this is an area of
great national concern you know I'm just
thinking about DHS we're trying to hire
a thousand people right now in cyber
security and we can't find them that
that can be our needs so there's a huge
market out there there's a huge need we
need to have a national effort in this
regard everybody's online everybody's on
the net all of our critical
infrastructure is cyber dependent this
has got to be something that is is much
higher in the public's consciousness I
believe then it currently is so no we're
not I think prepared enough and yes I
would agree with you that our education
system needs to do more in this way in
this area that I think it's I wonder
whether we have enough educators in the
system who are familiar with concepts of
cybersecurity to be able to help but we
certainly have We certainly have huge
huge huge needs in this regard now with
respect to China or attacks emanating
from China I don't I must say I don't
get too concerned about numbers you know
there's in some respects they may always
have more absolute numbers the question
is do you have the right kind of
individuals properly trained who can do
all the work you need done
and and there we still have efforts to
make thank you madam secretary my name
is Michael magic I'm a junior political
science and Russian studies major I was
wondering perhaps in light of Governor
Perry's recent comments regarding the
situation if you could offer some
insight into how higher priority you
feel the the Mexican drug cartels are
and what if any solutions you're
exploring at the moment regarding that
problem yeah well Mexico as you know has
been riven by a huge violence caused by
these drug cartels and they are large
organizations they they've been around a
long time but they've gotten larger
they've gotten more complex in terms of
their organizational structure they are
you know you you could say that there
are several states of mexico
particularly northern mexico where the
rule of law is at risk of being lost to
the cartels so this is a really
dangerous situation on the southern side
of our border and we're working a lot
with mexico on that and with the
Calderon administration there are a
number of efforts that have been
undertaken with them what what's
interesting is that the level of
violence right on the other side of the
Rio Grande or right on the other side of
the border is a very low and in fact
some of the safest communities in the
United States are right on our southern
border el paso for example right across
the bridge from Juarez Mexico one of the
most violent cities in the world I don't
know the reasons for that and well
there's speculation and one of the
speculation is that the the drug
organizations do their turf fighting on
the Mexican side but their families live
on the US side that's one explanation
that may explain a little bit of it we
have very strong law enforcement on the
US side that doesn't you know will be
prepared to to act very strongly if
something creeps over I think that maybe
another one a deterrent effect in other
words so a lot of reasons for that but
we're down there all the time and we're
in touch with the sheriff's down there
all the time and we're watching that
like a hawk because the last thing we
need in this country is spillover
violence of the type we've seen in
Mexico coming into our own southern
states thank you good afternoon madam
secretary my name is Jonathan yang I'm a
junior in the college from Southern
California in your opening remarks you
put Homeland Security squarely in the
umbrella national security more broadly
but looking at say the political
logistical difficulty if not impossible
plugging every hole as well as the
expansion of drone strikes and military
action other sort of pre-emptive
offensive proactive action how would you
characterize the current balance in US
national security policy between defense
and offense and do you see that shift
changing as threats evolved looking
further down the line well I think you
know one of the things that we've seen
is the ability with technology to be
able to take out some of the those who
have in our immediate dangers to the
united states with avek without having
to have a full commitment of ground
troops that's that's a major change and
I think we have to be careful and how
that's used I think we have to be very
thoughtful and by which those attacks
are sanctioned but they do give us some
some additional protections that we
didn't have even a few years ago and
quite frankly you know I think given
given what's out there in the type of
threats emanating against the United
States and the continued and expressed
desire to attack the west and to attack
our aviation system in particular and
that that's continually held up as like
the gold standard I I think that some of
these tactics are are well employed here
thank you you bet hello madam secretary
my name is Meghan Fitzpatrick I'm from
Buffalo New York and I'm a graduate
student in public health care so my
question is
maybe a little different now but my
group and I we were recently discussing
movie contagion and as well as the 1918
flu pandemic and the disastrous
consequences that an infection can cause
and we kept in mind the gentleman the
American citizen with mdr-tb who a few
years ago boarded a plane and put a lot
of people at very high risk and we were
unaware of any possible matter to detain
him or any ways that homeland security
could have protected against such an
incident with someone selfishly or
maliciously decides to bring a highly
infectious and difficult to treat or
potentially fatal disease into our
country and so I was wondering if the
Department of Homeland Security
currently has you think strong enough
measures to prevent such a contingency
or if you think that strengthening such
measures would be an invasion of privacy
that's just simply unacceptable for our
country well yeah and I can actually
remember a case where a guy who had
tuberculosis was trying to come from
Canada into Arizona actually and
intentionally and so you do have
occasional cases of that sort that's
where assuming you have knowledge you
know assuming you're not going to stand
at the gate to the airport and give
everybody a TB test or some other kind
of blood test which you know I think
we've gone about as far as we can go on
that score but assuming they're not
going to do that you have to have some
kind of prior knowledge but if you have
prior knowledge then we have some
combined authorities with the Centers
for Disease Control the public health
statutes of the country that I'll give
us some latitude on who we let in it
becomes trickier when it's somebody
who's actually a US citizen and they
have left the country and now they want
to come back and that's where I you have
to use a combination of persuasion and
incentives but it's that can be a very
difficult situation if somebody doesn't
want to cooperate and it so it's you are
right to say it's a little gap in the in
the system I haven't seen the movie yet
is it any good
I haven't seen either my friends have
just been talking about it okay thank
you yeah good afternoon I my name is
Katie Aragon I'm a sophomore in the
college from San Diego and I wanted to
ask you specifically about asylum
seekers and the long and traumatizing
process that they often are subjected to
once they're here in US borders I spoke
to a woman from Guatemala who had come
here seeking asylum asylum she was
fleeing from a very abusive home
situation and she was basing her case on
the fact that if she returned to
Guatemala she would face death and from
that point on she spent about two years
in a private Detention Center privately
owned which is paid per head by the
government and she ended up having to
effectively give her daughter over to
friends of friends to care for while she
was going through this process I'm
wondering if you could speak to the
possible conflict you that exist there
between these private detention centers
and if there are any efforts being made
to make this process faster and more
just yeah well I've already talked about
some of the things we're doing to
streamline the process and you know on
asylum you know asylum is a is you know
that is governed by law and there's a
fair amount of case law particularly the
Ninth Circuit on on asylum and asylum
claims there's always the possibility of
someone being paroled in on a
humanitarian basis but those those those
claims are that exercise of discretion
is limited as as well because many many
many of the asylum seekers always have
compelling cases these are you know
immigration systems are you know can can
there are hardships and and I keep
telling people look even when there is
immigration reform and I really hope
there is because this day
and the statutes we operate under really
are not well serving right now but even
when there is there will still be
individual cases like the one you
described now with respect to the
detention system the detention
facilities themselves yes we have
contracted with private detention space
but one of the first things we did when
we came in was to institute a whole
whole very extensive menu of detention
reforms and we applied them to our
private vendors as well as when we
contract with the public jail or what
have you and we cut off some of our
private vendors who didn't meet our
standards and we are constantly auditing
our private vendors and inspecting them
and making sure that those detention
centers meet standards for health both
physical and mental by the way and other
standards that we've set for them thank
you you bet hi my name is Daniel Simon
I'm a student at the law school my
question is about the excuse me aviation
security and passenger screening so you
mentioned in an earlier answer about the
responses that DHS has taken to address
some of the issues in preventing
terrorism in the aviation system but all
those responses at least to the public
eye sins have been reactive so there's
Richard Reed take off your shoes bombs
and printer cartridges you can't send
printers you know underwear bomber and
you install machines that look on to
people's underwear so it seems like if
you install these measures the day after
a method tactic is tried it's exactly
one day too late does the department
view this kind of reactive screening
strategy on this case by case and method
by method basis is something that is
going to continue going forward is it
going to change to more proactive
measures and specifically what is the
department's attitude towards things
like behavioral profiling toward what
sorry behavioral profiling of passengers
like kind of more along the lines of no
I don't want to say the Israeli system
because that involves a very kind of
expensive and big thing but I've heard
some discussion of taking some of the
behavioral profiling aspects of the
Israeli system and using that for
screening passengers rather than more
kind of an x-ray and pat down sort of
basis I couldn't understand the question
I can you back up from the mic dis
minute and then we get to get guys I'm
sorry can you hear me ok now yeah a
little bit speak more slowly let me see
if I can hear this sure i was asking
specifically in terms of changing
methods and overall strategy of
passenger screening mm-hmm is there an
idea of moving forward with the existing
strategy on a per tactical screening
basis screening of the person's body or
does the department have any thoughts
about moving towards more of a
behavioral profiling systems i gotcha so
many more akin to the israeli system i
got i got you okay sorry okay this is
what we're doing first of all yeah we do
look backwards when something has
happened and and make adjustments
accordingly now with respect to the
underwear bomber we were already in the
process of deploying the new AIT
machines well before then we'd already
been buying them why because the Intel
was telling us that the terrorists knew
that they needed if they could use an
explosive that didn't contain metal that
was a powder or a gel they increase
their ability to get through our last
layer of protection which is the actual
gate itself so the AIT s were looked
reactive but they were really in process
and we're and we are looking down the
road at a number of things one of them
is doing more risk-based screening what
does that mean it means that when we
have like prior knowledge about
passengers and we can begin
characterizing those who are frequent
travelers known travelers and and the
like we can begin making decisions about
whether they should get exactly the same
screening as someone about whom we know
nothing or who would fall in a high-risk
category so we are piloting that right
now we already have it in the
international realm it's a program
called Global Entry you can get a card
and it means you voluntarily agree you
pay a fee and you voluntarily agree to
give us some information
in exchange for which you get
accelerated through through the lines
with the caveat that there's always a
certain amount of random in anything
that we do in other words will always do
a little bit of random checking so
that's underway with respect to
behavioral screening itself we actually
have undercover officers in many
airports now and they use some of the
techniques that are based on what they
do in Israel they use some others as
well we have found in in looking at this
that it is very effective and that there
are really good good practices that can
be employed in that arena so when you
when you're talking about the airport
environment which is a very complicated
environment and the aviation system
which is a very complicated system
you're you're talking about many
different things that are going on
before you get to the airport while
you're at the airport but before you get
to the gate when you get to the gate and
when you get between the gate and the
jetway and there are layers now some
seen some unseen all of which are
designed to deal with threats that are
known or reasonably foreseeable to us
thank you thank you thank you my name is
Nora laprelli and I'm undocumented and
my question has to do with the morin
memo earlier this year which was
followed by the DHS announcement in
august 18 and my concern stems from the
fact that we have not seen a clear
implementation plan with the
announcement about how dream eligible
youth would not be placed in removal
proceedings and those as well as those
who are not currently in the system a
good friend of mine Mattias Ramos was
put in the super supervision program
about a month after the announcement
which forced to forces him to wear an
ankle bracelet and be up against the
wall to charge at three hours every day
so my questions are how will you ensure
that people who fit or meet this low
priority are in fact given or granted
deferred action
and how will you also ensure that as new
cases come in people are actually you
know classified as low priority and not
sent back to countries yeah there is
guidance going out to okla lawyers now
at the regional level and each of them
has has that guidance as to how to
review cases and how to look at cases
coming in the system what was
interesting is that the the lawyers in
the immigration arena did not view
themselves like assistant US attorneys
view themselves assistant US attorneys
view themselves as having discretion you
know an agent brings them a case they
decide whether or not they think it's
it's it's a priority case whether it's
worthy of a Court's time priorities are
set all through the criminal justice
system and I can say that as a federal
prosecutor and as a state prosecutor
every criminal justice system the
prosecutors are setting priorities what
was happening in the immigration system
is it was viewed more administrative
lipa were just moving cases along and
they took a long time and they were not
risk based in the sense that I just
talked about how we are moving to handle
other areas that we're dealing with and
so that we are now in the process and
guidance is going out to the field and
training is underway now about how to
exercise this question and how to do
that in reviewing the current caseload
and how to do that in reviewing cases
that are becoming into the system and
we're piloting some of that right now in
certain districts see how it works what
works doesn't work and but we will very
soon be going national thank you thank
you thank you all you've been great
thank you